there we go okay one kebab okay
i'll try it all right
this is the real deal nice are you sure
you're not pakistani
all right this is what i was looking for
fantastic all sorts of sweets
would not take money new york is the
best off
in the world it's my dream
they can cut through that thing weekly
come on
two minutes less than two minutes it's a
small machine like this
jesus good luck man thanks
take care what i love about new york
city
is that every nation in the world is
here in quantity
which means everyone's food is here so
today we're going to go out to jackson
heights in search of
the best or some of the best pakistani
food
in new york city
[Music]
please do your part to keep new york
healthy
[Music]
you don't want to be around here i want
to be around you period
i ain't actually telling who it was that
was surprising yeah
here we are at jackson heights queens
around the 1960s
many different ethnicities came into the
neighborhood a lot of latinos so you
have ecuadorians you have
argentinians you have colombians
and then you have napoleons bengalis
pakistanis
indians the goal is find the good eat
i have a i have a hot tip and uh
but most importantly meet some cool
people along the way
okay here we have an afghan kabob
what's uh napoli's place oh
you know where kebab is down there is it
good
i heard it's good yeah yeah all right
you guys from the neighborhood
yeah yeah tell me about the neighborhood
is it cool it's cool yeah it's cool
good food yeah cool it seems clean like
it's safe
yeah right on yeah thanks guys no
problem
so it's it's next blocked yeah okay
here we are
hello
[Music]
look at the chicken going onto the
fireplace
needing
[Music]
all right we're gonna do some of this
is this for me
yeah very nice thanks guys
thank you i think they thought i was a
cop or something
at first i just show them that i'm
making a youtube video
to get that access into the kitchen i
think i went a little bit simple i
actually didn't order this they they
just gave it to me some meat
onions lettuce a white sauce
very nice very nice there we go
right amount of spice very fresh meat
good seasoning
really loved it how you doing man
really good food
[Music]
you know the great thing about new york
is all the different neighborhoods every
every neighborhood has a different
identity i was out in the south bronx a
couple days ago
such a cool experience that was a real
eye-opener
it was it was a mix of like junkies
you know crackheads and very cool people
it was a proper mix hello how you doing
sir
pakistani and bangladesh nepali
and everyone gets along with the
nationalities that's cool
over there
that's a cool detail too about the
states is quite often when there
are say feuds between nationalities
you know hard histories and there you
know might be a
grudge or a rift that quite often goes
away
when they come into a foreign land
because they actually have more in
common
than uh different and so they you know
congregate together so bangladeshis
pakistanis indians
how are you doing i'm the rock
musician i'm the player kid a long time
before 27 years
i follow my idol is concerned with this
metallica definitely but
yeah duo james hadfield
metallica singer singer and guitarist
the panthera supporter
uh megadeth and
i don't marry him i am come here
one and a half years do you like new
york
new york is my heart new york is the
best
of in the world it's my dream it's
my dream and your dream came true your
dream came true
and i i achievement i achievement my
music
anywhere united states and i delegates
my life
you united states brother keep playing
get out there with the guitar okay next
time i play again
get out there with the guitar we need
some music here you know do you know her
yeah
[Music]
cool beautiful place what's the name
peter
peter you know peter is a famous name
peter yeah it's biblical
yeah yeah yeah right people take care
brother you too you too
nice to meet you you too you too bye-bye
i'm appreciate me to you
yeah inshallah you sure you're not
[Music]
pakistani
all right this is what i was looking for
fantastic all sorts of sweets i don't
know the names
i'm sure a lot of you guys do looks very
delicious
oh this is this um
i think this is that uh custard like a
sweetened custard i had this
in lahore i had this on the street in
lahore that's very good
[Music]
rice and it's sweet see how it compares
with the
here from pakistan
[Music]
nice it's like a it's custard some spice
in there i don't know what it is
it's sweet very sweet actually not as
good as
the streets of lahore i gotta say i did
eat
this fantastic dish on bread actually
in lahore and they actually gave it to
me that was interesting being in
pakistan they were actually giving me
food everywhere i went it would not take
money not the same in new york maybe new
york will take your money for sure
that's good it was a cool trip whenever
you have next trip man
allow me to come with you i will tell
you how to enjoy it all right
all right bro i know it's people were
cool like they invited me
everybody so fantastic
is this the most pakistani place here
this place you have a coney island too
more pakistanis out there or more here
over there
ah really i'm in the wrong community
oh so this is not the pakistani
community well this is
well they're they're mixed indian
bangladesh and everybody
[Music]
but there only pakistani community oh
i gotta go there next time come on man
so
it's really good to see you
i was just told there's a bigger
pakistani community in brooklyn
but oh well that was cool i enjoyed it
great food here hello sir alex
have a nice day and that's what's
beautiful about new york
is all of these diverse mixed up
neighborhoods with strong identities
hi guys how are you love your
neighborhood it's very cool out here
jackson heights check it out if you get
a chance and it's uh it's a very safe
approachable place
with excellent fit so until the next
video
see you then
[Music]
you